Trump is a guy that you've actually
you've met him yeah I think he many use
known for many years he was a fan of
your act how did you and you you kind of
did a deal with him once her asked him
to do a deal for you he uh when my
career took off like when I first met
you let's say yeah and I was it's not
alive and yeah huge and I was doing all
the arena shows I set up a meeting with
Trump and when I came to the meeting you
know the minute we met he's like so we
gonna be able to make a deal and I'm
like well yeah sure but that's not what
I'm here about you know I said you know
my sister lives in an apartment in one
of your buildings you know I gave her
the apartment it was on the sixth floor
of a sixth floor building and I told
them I go the neighbors on the 5th and
4th floor I've been complaining about
this leak you know and he's going yes so
I go well it's not coming from her
apartment mm-hmm so you gotta help me
out with this right something's wrong
with the building yeah and he goes
you're kidding me right
that's what this meetings about I go
it's your building so the next day my
sister calls me that three trucks pulled
up and they redid the entire roof of the
building and that was how I became like
friendly with Donald all right who I
called Donnie taste you had a good you
had a good experience with him yeah you
had a good experience I'm tired me off
of apprentice okay
[Laughter]
yeah I never I never you know watched
Celebrity Apprentice so I got the call
like the night before you want to do it
they said if Donnie really wants me to
do it I'll come in I'll do it
so martin scorsees Marty and the present
United States is Donnie well that's like
a nickname
Donnie T yeah yeah yeah I mean I'll call
mr. president you know like when I go
there to have a bite with him or
something yeah yeah I want to like show
me you know show me around happen you're
gonna get invited able to look around
the White House not after this show well
yes so you know they made they made us
bake on the show and me not knowing what
the show is about I figured okay they'll
cut to commercial they'll come back
they'll be 3,000 cupcakes right I didn't
know like I actually have to bake them
I'm good friends with Tom Green's like
my second best friend huh and he's on
the show with me oh no we got a bit I
said mo Baker yeah you know I gotta get
out of here you're gonna get me out of
this yeah you know I'm gonna stand here
like an idiot and just baked does it
what do I know so you were trapped on
Celebrity Apprentice yeah Donny Trump
yeah honey t told Tommy wouldn't get out
and what was funny is they normally fire
the leader yeah
but not on the one I was on
[Laughter]
you